I actually believe that most people know
what their passion is and what would
make them happy I believe most people
talk themselves out of it because they
think it's silly or they can't make
money and I keep telling people video
games was not a profession when I was
growing up but most of my friends were
passionate and almost all of them if
they just stayed the course into video
games would have made more money being a
video game podcaster than an executive
at a retail company a lawyer like I
think it's a pretty profound point of
view I think people know they just don't
want to say that I want to say because
they think they have to be Beyonce and
my point is just sing and make 53 000 a
year and live under 45 000 a year costs
but then you're happy because you're
[__] singing yes you do not have a
private plane but guess what most of the
people I know on Earth that have a
private plane are miserable so what the
[__] are we talking about here